why is PF crying like they win a ring or
something first off you can't write a
sentence the right way that's first off
before you get traded you get traded to
a spot where you know you get a chance
to win get a chance to win the
championship I got traded to the
Minnesota Timberwolves the team who
hasn't been in the playoffs I don't know
16 17 years whatever so before season
start I'm the guy who likes to go mirror
check Mira these are my goals these are
things I want to do I like to manifest
things I like to speak things into exist
distance I wanted to make sure this team
went to the playoffs that was my only
goal that's the only thing I wanted to
do we did it we did it against the team
that traded me I asked the team that
traded me for money they didn't want to
give it to me Minnesota gave it to me we
beat them knocked them out the playoffs
we're going to the playoffs emotions
build up I'm happy as is a man allowed
to be happy why do we always have to cry
like tears of pain we can't Cry tears of
joy